foreign welcome back to this special
edition of Hannity tonight multiple
high-profile officials are speaking out
against New York D.A Alvin Bragg
including Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
who accused Bragg of quote weaponizing
his office so what do the people of New
York think about their own district
attorney joining us now with a full
report Fox News contributor Sarah Carter
good evening Sarah
good evening Judge Jeanine I spent the
afternoon here in New York City talking
to folks about how they felt about
Manhattan district attorney Alvin Bragg
and you know many of them echoed the
exact same sentiments as Governor Ron
DeSantis of Florida take a listen
we're here in New York City you've
obviously heard about President Trump's
possible upcoming indictment right
what's going through your mind when you
hear about that it's upsetting because
are our very own um
livelihood was actually so much better
under Trump's presidency I know a lot of
problems came when Once Biden came I'm
not too political but I know that's the
thing I think the D.A should probably
focus more on local crime we live up on
the Upper East Side so
I think crime around the streets is
probably more of a problem than
Prosecuting Trump right now do you think
maybe you should spend more time here
taking care of what's going on in this
city absolutely absolutely yeah
definitely you know the places that are
the most popular like Grand Central Penn
Station the you know the commuter places
definitely need to be cleaned up more
and they need to focus on those places
yeah do you think it has anything to do
too with not Prosecuting people for
crimes yeah most definitely yeah
definitely
three percent in crime and a Manhattan
district attorney Alvin Bragg also
reduced felonies to misdemeanors by 52
percent the people of New York City are
more concerned about what's happening
here in their own Community than they
say targeting president Trump which
would which is what appears to be a
weaponized use of this prosecution judge
well you know I I must tell you Sarah
it's fascinating to hear people talk
about it you know it's not sometimes I
think it's not just an issue of you know
he's weaponizing the criminal justice
system he's literally ignoring victims
in this city and this city is now a high
crime city it went from one of the
safest cities in the country large
cities I think the safest to a disaster
because he won't prosecute crime anyway
Sarah Carter great to see you thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else